BUT FIRST AGENTS ARE SUFFERING.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
THIS IS ANOTHER BUSY "NEWSWEEK"
IN THREE MAJOR EVENTS OCCURS
DEMONSTRATES HOW RADICAL AND HOW
DANGEROUS THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BECOME.
NOW I KNOW, IT SOUNDS HYPERBOLIC
BUT BEAR WITH ME.
THE EVIDENCE IS MOUNTING THAT
JOE BIDEN’S PARTY FROM ELDERS TO
ORGANIZERS HAS ADOPTED A BYE ANY
MEANS NECESSARY APPROACH TO
WINNING IN NOVEMBER.
AND THE CONSEQUENCES FOR AMERICA
WILL BE DEVASTATING IN BOTH THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM.
FIRST, IF YOU THOUGHT THAT WE
COULD FIND BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT
THAT RIOTING SHOULD NEVER BE
TOLERATED, THINK AGAIN.
IN FACT, THERE SEEMS TO BE AN
IMPLICIT CONSENSUS AMONG
DEMOCRATS TODAY THAT EFFORTS
SHOULD NOT BE MADE TO STOP
FEDERAL BUILDINGS FROM ARSON.
OR EVEN TO STOP A TAX ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AT ALL.
AT THE DISGRACEFUL INQUISITION
OF AG BILL BARR THIS WEEK,
DEMOCRAT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
GAVE COVER TO ACTUAL CRIMINALS
AND TREATED BAR LIKE HE WAS THE
PROBLEM.
>> SHAME ON YOU MR. BURKE MY
SHAME ON.
>> I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
ANOMALY.
>> FOR PROTESTERS.
>> NO, FOR RIOTERS.
>> OR THAT’S MY QUESTION, FOR
PROTESTERS.
MR. BARR EXCUSE ME, THIS IS MY
TIME, SIR, SIR.
>> I DON’T THINK THAT WAS HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY AROUND THE THE
COURTHOUSE WAS A PEACEFUL
PROTEST.
>> THAT IS NOT MY QUESTION,
MR. BARR.
YOU ARE CLAIMING MY TIME, YOU
ARE CLAIMING MY TIME.
>> Laura: EVERY AMERICAN WHO
VOTES IN NOVEMBER SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY WILL ALLOW TOTAL MAYHEM TO
GO UNCHECKED AND LIFE’S WORK
DESTROYED IF PERPETRATORS ARE
ANTI-TRUMP.
YOU HAVE THE RIGHT MOTIVE, THEY
WILL LEAVE YOU ALONE.
NOW, WE LEARNED IN NEW YORK
ALONE AT THE HEIGHT OF ITS
PROTEST, ABOUT $1 MILLION IN
DAMAGE WAS DONE JUST TO THE
POLICE CARS THAT WERE DESTROYED.
AND THE DAMAGE TO BUSINESSES WAS
LIKELY IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS.
THE CITIES A TOTAL NOW WITH
SKYROCKETING CRIME INCLUDING
MURDER RATES GOING WAY UP.
WHO ♪
♪ AND de BLASIO A DUO OF
DISASTER.
BUT THEY DON’T CARE.
IT’S ALL ABOUT THEM ASKING MORE
POWER FOR THEM, MORE CONTROL FOR
THEM AND HURTING THE PRESIDENT’S
CHANCES FOR REELECTION.
NOW, ANOTHER INDICATION THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE GONE TOTALLY NUTS
THOUGH IS THEIR FAMED
HYPERVENTILATION YESTERDAY ABOUT
TRUMP’S TWEET ABOUT MAIL IN
VOTING AT THIS QUESTION OF
DELAYING THE ELECTION.
NOW THEY ALL KNOW HE DOESN’T
HAVE THE POWER TO DO THAT NOR
WAS HE EVEN SAYING THAT HE WOULD
TRY TO DO THAT.
FOR GOOD REASON, THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES THAT MALE AND VOTING
WOULD BE A NIGHTMARE THAT WOULD
END UP DELAYING ELECTION RESULTS
FOR WEEKS, EVEN MONTHS.
AND THAT IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
THEMSELVES HAVE REPEATEDLY SAID
TO.
>> WE ARE WORKING TO PREPARE YOU
AND THE PUBLIC TO NOT GET THE
RESULTS IMMEDIATELY CLOSING OUT
ELECTION NIGHT.
IT MAY WELL TAKE SEVERAL MORE
DAYS.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS ARE
MADLY PUSHING IN MAIL-IN VOTING
FOR ONE REASON.
THEY THINK IT WOULD HELP THEM
BEAT TRUMP.
THEY KNOW, AND THEY DON’T EVEN
CARE IT CAN LEAD TO FRAUD AND
CORRUPTION.
THERE ARE ALREADY PLENTY OF
EXAMPLES OF THAT INCLUDING MOST
RECENTLY NEW JERSEY.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE FINE WITH
MILLIONS UP AND TRACKABLE AND
SOMETIMES UNTRACEABLE MAIL-IN
BALLOTS FLOATING AROUND
UNDERMINING THE ELECTORAL
SYSTEM, CAUSING CONFUSION,
INSTABILITY, AND EVEN VIOLENT
UNREST FOR DAYS OR WEEKS AFTER
ELECTION DAY.
TO THEM MADE IT JUST ENDS UP IN
BEING ANOTHER INSURANCE POLICY
TO HELP BIDEN.
THIRDLY, IT IS OBVIOUS THE
DEMOCRATS, INCLUDING BIDEN, WANT
AMERICA TO SHUT DOWN AGAIN WITH
NEWER AND EVEN MORE DRACONIAN
CONTROLS OVER YOUR MOVEMENT.
>> YOU CAN’T GET THIS COUNTRY
GOING AGAIN UNLESS YOU GET COVID
UNDER CONTROL.
>> WE DO NOT EXPECT TO OPEN IF
THE VIRUS IS SPREADING
UNCHECKED.
>> AND CONGRESS UNDERSTANDS WHY.
AND TO CONTAIN THE VIRUS.
>> WHEN THEY SHUT DOWN OR LOCKED
DOWN WITH SHELTER IN PLACE,
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO DESCRIBE IT,
THEY REALLY DID IT TO THE TUNE
OF ABOUT 95 PLUS PERCENT.
>> THAT’S WHAT WE SHOULD HAVE
DOWN, SHUT IT ALL DOWN AND STAY
INSIDE AND WAIT FOR THE MAILBOX
MONEY.
WELL OUR TERRIBLE GDP NUMBERS
RELEASED FOR THE SECOND QUARTER
ARE DUE ENTIRELY TO
UNEMPLOYMENT, AND OF COURSE,
THAT IS CAUSED BY THE SHUTDOWN.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS IN THE
TOILET.
KIDS WILL BE STUCK AT HOME
LOOKING AT SCREENS AND MUCH OF
AMERICA THIS FALL, HURTING THEM
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS JUST CONSIDER
IT ALL NECESSARY POLITICAL
COLLATERAL DAMAGE ON THE WAY
THAT THEY HOPE TO BEATING
DONALD TRUMP.
OH, BY THE WAY, THE EUROZONE
RELEASED ITS NUMBERS TODAY AND
THEY ARE IN A FULL-BLOWN
RECESSION, THE WORST ON RECORD.
FRANCE’S ECONOMY SHRANK BY
NEARLY 14% IN THE
SECOND QUARTER.
SPAIN FARED EVEN WORSE.
THERE GDP CONTRACTED 19%.
THAT IS DOUBLE WHAT WE LOST.
THE DEMOCRATS CONSIDER ALL OF
THIS A SUCCESS STORY?
AND FINALLY TODAY, THIS TOOK THE
CAKE, SENATE DEMOCRATS LEFT TOWN
RATHER THAN AGREE TO A
SHORT-TERM EXTENSION OF
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PROPOSED
BY REPUBLICANS.
AND EVEN CNN COULDN’T SPIN THE
DEMOCRATS BEHAVIOR.
>> WHILE THERE WERE OFFERS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE TO TEMPORARILY
EXPAND THIS EXTRA $600 A WEEK
BENEFIT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
ARE DEPENDING ON, THE
DEMOCRATS DIDN’T AGREE TO THAT.
THE FEAR IS THAT IF YOU LET THIS
GO AS A STAND-ALONE BILL, YOU
LOSE LEVERAGE IN FUTURE
NEGOTIATIONS.
>> Laura: LEVERAGE?
DID YOU HEAR THAT QUESTION MIGHT
LEVERAGE!
THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE REAL LIVES
AT STAKE.
SO INSTEAD OF ACTING IN THE
NATION’S BEST INTEREST,
DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING ONCE AGAIN
TO SEE NEEDLESS PAIN INFLICTED
ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
BECAUSE YOU SEES HUMANS
DIFFERENT TO THEM IS USELESS.
IF IT GETS THEM CLOSER TO
SOCIALISTIC UTOPIA OF MASSIVE
INCREASE WITH PEOPLE DEPEND ON
THE GOVERNMENT AND A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN STATE CONTROL OVER
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR LIVES.
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY WE SEE
DEMOCRATS CHOOSE CHAOS OVER
COMMON SENSE.
THEY ARE OKAY WITH TRASHING THE
COUNTRY’S ECONOMY.
TAX PAYER PROPERTY AND HISTORY.
THEY ARE FINALLY EMIGRATING
CABINET MEMBERS AS PART OF A
SHOW FOR THE CAMERA.
AND THEY ARE OKAY WITH HURTING
CHILDREN WITH POLLS PANIC ABOUT
SCHOOL REOPENING.
AND FINALLY, THEY WILL LET YOU
TWIST IN THE WIND INSTEAD OF
WORKING WITH REPUBLICANS.
THIS ENTIRE YEAR HAS BEEN A
POST-IMPEACHMENT REVENGE QUEST
FOR DEMOCRATS.
AND THEY ONLY HATE TRUMP,
REMEMBER BECAUSE THEY HATE THE
AMERICA THAT ELECTED HIM.
THEY NEED THAT AMERICA TO GET SO
DEMORALIZED THAT THEY STOP
FIGHTING FOR THEIR OWN LIVES AND
LIBERTY.
BUT THEY’VE MADE A REALLY RISKY
BET WITH THIS COURSE THEY ARE
ON, AND THEY’VE GONE ALL IN, BUT
SO MUST WE.
WE ALL THAT MUCH TO OUR
CHILDREN, OUR GRANDCHILDREN, AND
THOSE WHO CAME BEFORE US.
SO LET’S STOP COMPLAINING AND
START DOING.
REGISTER PEOPLE TO VOTE AND